[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'ai encore un son journal tous les
modèles
j'espère qu'elles seront sociaux tel
brian grant hors tabac fnpt à barzy base
son coup si les petits commerçants
[Musique]
le petit écho de la forêt c'est un truc
très serré roulait vers eux il y à
toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception ça vous le découvrirez dans le
décor de l'offre e
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyant voyant les petites annonces aum
elles sont vraiment petit en bas que
voilà qui est intéressant cher téléphone
ouverture d'un cours de chant à court de
chantillac ah tiens très intéressant
très intéressant vous vous êtes réfère
mal mais il ya mashov la voie à l
bouillir et vous brûlez les trains
puissent assister au coup de chaud et
c'est ainsi que tout le petit monde de
la forêt se réunit pour assister aux
cours de shows donnés par isa dorin
ancienne chanteuse de l'opéra le jeune
boris viven s'il est ce là la classe où
tu sais tu es bien bonus
tout commence sa gamme moi pas osé c'est
donc moi avoir oublié l'autre tout la
tente est cependant facile allez tous en
choeur
ibra fall à savoir ma leçon 4 do ré mi
fa sol la si moi plus avoir le suis jeté
trop tourner à gammarth et moi pas
besoin pour monter au suivant la fin du
cours
isadora avait donné des devoirs à chacun
de ses élèves
je m'adapte aux vip nous visitent écoute
d'eau a uni sa sol la si do wah est très
mal eux jamais savoir gamme supportant
facile écoutes dont comme domino comme
et domino à marennes chance et qu'on mer
et des choses me comme midi
mais pas comme et moustapha sall sol il
le lendemain au cours de chant de
mademoiselle isadora de l'opéra donc on
met domino récupérer des chaussées mais
comme me dit pas comme moustapha sol
comme tournesol la comète lalala qui
commet russie donne comme et dodo et
billets boursiers dit barry et
maintenant tout son coeur comme lots
dont suis comme vichy la commettra yaya
sonko mettre le son rock rob et most of
fame mais kobe midi gré robert et des
sauces et autres ob domino
oh j'ai l'impression que notre boris sur
un très grand acteur d'opéra
n'est ce pas le chercher les fans à
bientôt pour une nouvelle édition du
petit écho de la forêt mais ferguson
encore